I used to want to save the world
this beautiful place but the closer you
get the more you see the great darkness
within
I learned this the hard way a long long
time ago
what is your mission to stop the war
what war the war to end all wars
weapons far deadlier than you can ever
imagine
the wall can be ours
where we are you are more danger than
you think cannot stand by while innocent
lives are lost
be careful Diana
who is this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what i'm going to do
[Music]
how can a woman possibly fight in this
fight we use our principles although I
am NOT opposed to engaging in a bit of
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
hey youtubers new Wonder Woman best damn
secretary I ever had so let's break it
down so there's so much going on to this
it's more of like a story trailer that
kind of explains a little bit more about
how she came to leave society along with
famous Kira and the rest of the Amazons
but it also confirms that the movie is
going to take place during two different
time periods like you see her here in
present day during like Batman V
Superman era walking by the Louvre as
someone who is long-lived like they
explained that her job in modern day is
something of like an antiquities dealer
but most of the movies going to be set
in world war one era you see Steve
Trevor's airplane crash here she goes
and rescues him he explains that he's
trying to stop the war to end all wars
that's World War one which ironically
was not the war to end all wars because
we got World War two so just to be clear
these aren't Nazis you know usually
people tend to see German troops in
period pieces and just assume that
they're Nazis but we get a better look
at what's going on with the villains dr.
poison I think this just confirms that
this character here she is dr. poison so
she's just kind of like the Arnim Zola
to Danny Houston's red skull although
just to be clear the captain america
movie was World War two but just look at
the way they use color in this trailer
especially when they're on Themis gear
like it's meant to be Paradise Island so
of course it looks like paradise with
all the colors blown out but most of the
narration in the trailer is from the
present-day Wonder Woman she's talking
about stuff as it happened like she's
remembering all this so when these
troops are charging the Amazons on the
beaches and thymus Kira this is the
German troops invading at some point in
the movie so this is probably like well
after Steve Trevor crashes on their
beach but the thing I'm really curious
to find out is that obviously dr. poison
in the Germans are developing war
weapons you know based on world war one
technology but you get a little teaser
for Wonder Woman's demigod origin sees
the daughter of Zeus in hippolytus ear
so maybe there's something that the
Amazons have that the Germans want that
will make them even more powerful it's
just a real question of like how
grounded in the real world they're going
to keep this movie because we know about
the mother boxes we know about dark side
so just a question of how
crazy they get with that more
otherworldly stuff in the movie as
opposed to just keeping it a world war
one piece with a really badass Wonder
Woman just trying to stop everything
from going to hell but that really is
why she wants to help Steve Trevor
because she sees all this craziness
happening and she just wants to stop the
world from ripping itself apart so a big
part of the movie is just explaining why
Wonder Woman is such an important
character in why the world needs her but
kind of in the background just don't
forget that they have the overstory
that's linking all these things together
with the mother boxes the Justice League
story so that'll be in the background
too but most of this is just going to be
a lot of Wonder Woman badassery and one
of the most fun things about her
character besides her soundtrack which
is really badass it sounds like
something right at a game of thrones but
it's the way they film her action so
there are a couple inherent problems
when you film superman action scenes
that I think they've worked around
because they depowered Wonder Woman a
little bit like she doesn't fly she's
more like Golden Age Superman power
level so they don't have to slow the
frames down too much when she's like
spinning around and just going crazy on
all these dudes so it's just like a
really cool way to differentiate her
fighting style from that of Batman which
is just as vicious but obviously it's
not quite as quick or quite as powerful
and then Superman who moves so fast that
he's kind of like a dot just zooming
around in the frame hopefully in Justice
League will actually see some really
cool Superman action scenes too but I
think it's a little bit easier to do
with Wonder Woman because she doesn't
move that fast and she's kind of like an
in-between power level between Batman
and Superman but let me know in the
comments like what are your favorite
types of action scenes I felt like one
of the best things they did in Batman V
Superman was the way they film batman
action there was so little of Wonder
Woman that you didn't really get a good
taste for it but this is a much better
example of what her fighting style is
going to look like during Justice League
just imagine her fighting parademons
things that are much more powerful so
she doesn't have to hold back quite as
much but I love the way they used that
1920s humor at the like how do you fight
in this freaking giant dress I don't get
it like what the hell is going on here
so just expect a lot of funny moments
with like the gauntlet reveals like you
know she's completely
burn up here so you wouldn't be able to
tell her apart from any other random
woman just walking around so let me know
what do you guys think of the trailer I
feel like this is a much better trailer
than the last one but so far they've
actually been really good trailers I
love the way the action looks I love the
way they filmed it like it just looks so
beautiful compared to the other DC
movies so far and I think it'll do a
really good job of differentiating the
tone of wonder woman's character from
the other DC characters we've seen so
far because you know like Batman very
different character very different types
of stories than Wonder Woman also very
different from Superman very different
from the flash as well like they're all
very different characters so it'll be
interesting to see how they weave all
this together during Justice League
speaking of which though there is a
rumor that we're gonna get the first big
Justice League trailer like an actual
trailer around Christmas time so just
expect a whole bunch more justice league
stuff to happen at the end of the year
but we are almost a year away from
Justice League actually hitting theaters
that's going to be a november movie next
year so get high it's going to be
awesome so later today i'll be posting
arrow human target and my doctor strange
spoiler review but i'll wait till post
that till later in the night so
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
see the movie be sure and go see dr.
strange also really weird really
different movie from the Marvel stuff
you've seen so far it's a lot of fun
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click down here for like the last
big Justice League trailer and you can
click here for the next big flash
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you